rega soli belli siamo tanti su minecraft
parkour episodio 65 però capito vi piace
a buona visione
bravo vieni qua mi comino allora
dobbiamo scendere abbiamo capito capito
aspetta fermatevi a stare qua non così
perché devono mettere il ghiaccio in
tutti i livelli noi donna che mi fa si
vogliono non ci posso credere
io non ci voglio credere dai non farlo
dai non riesco io amico no da darsi
scemo
c'è poi la parte difficile quella pagina
[Risate]
tattica facciamo così la donna menarci
dove o meno frutta che gira le balle
alla cestra mai perenne ok ce l'ha fatta
no no stando le cose fosse sul telefo
non è vero da william howard sia privati
livello quello che era tutto muratone so
che figo che se starò non c'è da fare
qua c'è una parte nascosta next rai c'è
scritto mi sa che dobbiamo andare tutta
che però non è di qua queste per
confonderci sicuro anche secondo me la
vera prima sulle scale però come come
chiariamo che il soffitto non puoi
saltare o bravissimo mai fatto non lo so
ok
comico vivo ti rivedo non puoi
incazzarti dai gesù gesù finalmente mio
addio quanto difficile doveva essere
stati 26 st roba parkour parchi ciao
bravissima andiam andiam andiam andiam
portare le land by filati scherzavo
amico pettini aiuto
domani si chiude dunque c'è qualcosa va
sotto l'acqua perfetto ma momo tra
l'altro per un attimo mi sono pagato
ok cioè una due tre o le visto il figo
ed a quanti la cosa vedo già sbagliato
c'è una cosa il sotto c'è una roba di
sly ma occhio a caldo vado con lo slime
l'ho chiamato aspetta c'è una cosa che
non ho capito aspetta aspetta fermo io
sono arrivato alla fine non ho capito
non fare domande vieni l'abbiamo fatto
era difficilissimo ma non aspetta
secondo me c'è qualcosa di strano nel
possibile tu così è finito metà
leggo perfetto ce l'hai fatto no per
ecco dove come sei andato via sono
riuscito subito ma io quando tu non ci
sei faccio le cose solo quando non ci
sei
ma smettere lo slime che il collega 3
perfetto calcio di bravissimo a ok
perfetto e mo devo arrivare alla fine ma
siete scemi che prova a schiacciare al
volo verso la fine che non so cosa su ok
ma quale piace o sfruttata una colonna
piace voglia che male e ma rimane per
niente è come un essere umano come
dovrebbe riuscire a farsi spiega mi è
venuto live poker
bravo two bevande soprattutto avanti mai
ciao ciao amico ci sia fatta ci vediamo
la prossima ragazzi è stato bello avere
pietra in questa serie non spiegano come
dovresti fare a bravo bravo bravissimo
provaci
ma come è non lo so ha un aspetto c'è un
buco di per terra bravo o board e vanta
zarda ammazzo da che parte devo saltare
qua una sfera della sera veniva
legnolegno ora slime del mio posto è sì
in india quella però che casino devo
fare io è uno ma mica sono scemo come
migliore fermi tutti fermi per forza
ciao amici
scherzavo adesso lo rifaccio faccia
adesso lo faccio giusto si era vera un
allenamento non mi il dio o mentre
mangia cioccolata fortissimo guardare
invece a posto
ok è adesso c'è la parte finale madonna
conto difficile ma no eh ma il problema
adesso uno due tre quattro blocchi piano
amico amico solo il giocatore più forte
del mondo a dovere forte lo giuro negli
enti aspetto m
poi la parola camomilla un tè milano
mangia cioccolato ma direi smette mai
realtà non ho come lo provoca non è per
fa schifo questa roba vedo sai noi
succede ma se succede
allora ragazzi mi piace mai cantato
tranquillo potete rilassarvi passare ore
in compagnia dei vostri amici
dopo una giornata di studio distende i
nervi che è una meraviglia spettava
prova vederti in salvo ho detto visto
che ho visto e ho visto l'altro facevi
tu vieni vieni vieni vieni qua questa è
la cagata o la che vedo quando vi ha
trovato un ritmo
ok erano ragioni abbiamo fatto vedere
che cosa c'è chi sei un po rotto le
balle l'islam a don quindi attore
saltare da 16 me all'altro e pure
difficile
sì ma perché rimbalzi poi quei mi
rimbalzi ni no è impossibile è un
problema da quanto ho capito che parla
tutto in corso devo farlo già fatta
ma secondo me davies attardarmi sopra su
questo su un secondo
tendi da soli 100 test ecco mi ci sono
26 sono qua cavolo ha effetto perfetto
ma all amico arrivo coincide arrivo a
milano facile arrivo a questo si ride no
e io ho fatto tutto cercando mi sono
trascinato verso la tv ci sta il bravo
mi ha dato una così utile aprire poi qua
no l'abbia con macerie o che glie l'ho
fatto ma avrebbe dopo un macello
aspettare poi però nella semplice era
semplice ma molto più semplice di quanto
pensato l'altro portare le land spetta
fermo c'è una scala per occhio e addio
c'è un sottolivello a nome che avevi
paura mi sono caga tissimo miti come
vediamo da vedere ok quali parte o tutto
sul kart così scemo ok cavalca anch'io
ho sbagliato alla fine perché sono fatta
già fatta una che fenomeno alla fine non
ha anche saltato non so come ho fatto
olè olè baby all è un bravo bravissimo
botanico nascosto sia perché la porta
però c'è qualcosa di esplode per cosa è
successo di là e non lo so non ho mai
capito
apri
grazie amico prego mentre se il io vado
un po quanto arriverò che torniamo a
domani fino a domani eto'o rimane non so
come fare amico ci aiuterai davvero se
non fossi finito nella lava della morte
della vita nel livello semplicissimo
questo accade ci metti un ora per
tornare indietro o mi chiami sono cagato
addosso ti giuro era un jobs ha fatto
aspetta aspetta report cavalca e un
livello facilissimo sono fosse che è una
cagata ma io sto andando a fuoco
poi fatto si guarda ancora vado a fuoco
basta mai ok
poiché la la porca vacca quaeda fosse un
caso umano tour madonna
se quindi ragazzi questo era il video di
minecraft harcourt spero che vi sia
piaciuto continuano nel prossimo
episodio continueremo nel prossimo
episodio comunque e sempre più veramente
sempre più figo sto gioco piaciuta meno
male che abbiamo iniziato una serie
decente madonna e capelli va beh spero
che vi sia piaciuto ma se non ti piace
ancora italiani si astiene scegliamo
prossimi
la ragazza
[Musica]